all your data as long as you want to be
getting a virtual medical coach all your
data will be continually inputted and
assimilated and fed back to you in terms
of guidance mm-hm
and as soon as we get the text part
straight it'll also be the entire
medical literature pertaining to you
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sockin we
are on-site at scripps research
translational institute in the beautiful
Torrey Pines California we are now going
to be talking about deep medicine we
have dr. Eric Topol joining us on the
show hello good to see you know thank
you so much for coming on really
appreciate it it was you did such a
great job on Sam Harris's podcast and I
was really grateful that so many of my
friends have been constantly pushing me
they're like have you had Eric on the
show yet get Eric on the show see if we
can make it happen so you have a lot of
fans around the world that are that love
your work and for those that don't know
Eric's bio Eric Topol is a world
renowned cardiologist executive VP of
Scripps Research Institute one of the
top 10 most cited medical researchers
and author of several books most
recently deep medicine how a I can make
healthcare human again and you can find
all the links in the bio below to
Scripps profile page wikipedia page
twitter as well as the link to deep
medicine the book all right Eric let's
start things off by asking you what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world well it's a big question a lot to
unpack there but you know I think if it
is in the world of medicine and life
science and I'm really excited about it
I think that we're on the cusp of real
extraordinary unparalleled time it's
very much in contrast to some of the
other problems we're confronting but
this is largely because we've been
accumulating data up until recent times
we didn't know what to do with it and of
course now with deep learning
and these different types of artificial
intelligence we're going to take this to
a level that I think many of us might
not even have envisioned happening more
quickly than what I think even some of
the most optimistic folks could have
foreseen so having been a student of
Medicine and in life science for a few
decades this to me is is really
enthralling I'm excited to unpack the
nuance of it with you one of the things
that is so important is having
structured data that's one of the most
important things and the other one is
having the stream of relatable
biometrics that we take from the body
actually be effectively processed to
predict pathologies to augment our
health all this type of stuff how do you
foresee that most effectively happening
well first on the structured data is
really a limitation today because that
works really well for images because
using algorithms to discern and
interpret an image it's already a
structured substrate it's a perfect
input a speech as well but when you get
to text that's where you start to see a
drop-off because a lot of text is
unstructured and we're just starting to
see a turning point there there was this
really remarkable work published in
Nature on material science where with
unsupervised learning being able to
start to get these embedded texts and
trying to recognize text but right now
that the idea that like for example IBM
Watson put out that a doctor could read
5,000 articles and then go see patients
well we're not there yet because most
things that are published in the
literature are unstructured and you
still need ability to read and
comprehend
we haven't gotten machines there yet but
that's kind of the last of the three
with images leading the charge speech
not somewhat behind but not that far
behind and then Texas
is certainly the one that's trailing now
the other thing you asked about which is
about the biometric stream being most
effectively pre for predicting the
pathologies and fragmenting our health
yeah I mean that this is an explosion of
being able to wealth interpretation
classification is really sharp and again
that's relying on a lot on images what
we don't have so well really is
prediction and you look at it you know
we we've got a lot of shots on goal with
will predict the person that's gonna
live in the hospital or they're gonna be
admitted from the hospital perhaps
actually the best paper on prediction
study just came out recently but I had
the privilege of writing the editorial
for nature that only the second paper
that's been published in nature for AI
in medicine and it was about kidney
injury and it happens very frequently in
patients in the hospital one in five
which is alarming and it's a big deal
because if somebody has significant
kidney injury they could go on to
requiring dialysis and possibly
transplant or even dying so we want to
be able to predict it because those are
the people that we want to have
exclusive control of their fluids and
their blood pressure and what
medications or contrast dye all these
different things that could happen to
them and so since we have this very high
prevalence of one in five if we can get
that down to you know one in a hundred
it probably never be perfect that would
be exciting so that's a more granular
prediction rather than someone going to
die or not and that's the first time
we've seen organ injury prediction but
it has to be something that's actionable
so one of the problems we have is we got
these things that are prediction like
Alzheimer's well okay but what are you
gonna do about it so that is an issue
today is we're bringing able to predict
things it's fuzzy it's not as nearly as
high in accuracy as an image
interpretation
but it's obviously a lot of works going
into it most of the work is
retrospective going backwards yeah
in computer data sets that are all
pristine assembled and the data are all
cleaned up they're not in the real world
prospectively when you're trying to make
predictions and seeing whether they
really come true so that is a more
challenging thing and very few
prediction studies fit into that group
of going forward and that's what we
desperately need Erik what would you say
is the wants some of some of the most
important principles and skills for us
to embody for keeping our homeostatic
capacity in the youthful State for as
long as possible to increase our
longevity yeah well it's a great
question I want to give we knew you know
that would be fantastic I wish I knew
you know I think that we're learning
about this there is of course a big boom
in heat in the science of aging and
learning the biology which we didn't
know about even you know a few years ago
I think turning that into commercial
entities is troubling because they are
often way ahead of where the science or
the the proof lies but you know one of
the things that's exciting to me is this
food is medicine stolen yeah because if
we could what we eat if we were using
that instead of medicines or augmenting
effects of medicines yeah that would be
ideal
and we're just chipping away at that now
so that to me is one of the signposts
that we're really making progress so
whereas up until a few years ago it was
just everyone's unique the same diet and
we don't have any real good story in
fact we don't have data to back that up
the the studies and nutrition have been
very shaky most of them are not
randomized trials they're observational
so they have all sorts of issues of
limitations
and so we've been left in the lurch and
we've had guidelines and food pyramids
and they're all really basically you
know kind of a cockamamie mess you know
no one knows what really they should be
eating lines of perverse incentives -
yeah fake foods and we can get a little
into the fake physicians as well but
just perverse incentives all around in
lack of inclusive steak holding so that
I used to give you food for your optimal
health because it would also help our
tribes health and whatnot and now it
seems in many ways that we deliver food
for self-dealing purposes so that I can
earn more money no matter what the
quality of food is and similarly with a
physician that is potentially again
getting a little bit of under the mut
under-the-table money for things that
the patient doesn't need and that when
there's a lack of inclusive steak
holding between the outcome of the
patient as well as the physician and
these time blocks are whatever twenty
minutes to see a patient and there's the
electronic health record and the
keyboard the focus on that instead of
that deep empathy with the patient I
mean there's so many of these variables
that we need to really figure out what
is most optimal for health care yeah
well and we know that a diet is as part
of that story I mean obviously exercise
is part of it you know being at the
right weight and being fit is important
but the diet part has been the the zone
of uncertainty and what's changed there
is that using AI we've cracked the case
that each person has a very unique
individual response and in fact even
identical twins are very different and
the reason for that is partly because of
the gut microbiome which is just blossom
in terms of being such a big player into
determining our health but also you know
all these other factors like you know
your your physical activity your sleep
your stress level your met
so once we get all that data on each
person and you have a glucose sensor on
you can find out what foods are the ones
that are driving if you have any which
is not uncommon these very big spikes in
glucose which are undesirable we don't
know fully in a healthy person who has
glucose spikes we don't know the
long-term significance of that and
whether we should do everything we can
to prevent them oblate them or at least
reduce them and now we're also seeing
the same with these triglyceride spikes
so the point being is that although we
don't have outcomes to say oh well if
you eat these certain foods for you this
is your alan your personalized
individualized diet if you stay on that
that will prevent cancer or heart attack
or autoimmune diseases we don't have
that yet what we have are these
intermediate markers like this is your
glucose and if you stay away from these
certain foods and and shift more to
these you can keep your glucose flat or
you can keep your triglycerides flat and
that probably will translate over time
but the point is we didn't even know
that it four years ago so we're making
progress it's not a commercial story yet
in my view but maybe in the next few
years it may start to be so diet is is a
biggie but I think in terms of the aging
process for the most part it's very
difficult to affect that you may have
some soft modulation but you know we
don't know anything that really is you
know there's been all these false starts
there was rezip very tall and there all
these things that were to affect a
person's and people just obviously the
cryotherapy I mean all sorts of things
and none of them have actually the
science to back them up in people and in
a mouse you can do almost anything and
get them in mice to live longer so that
is not a representative model for humans
our endeavor into more precise
personalized medicine and nutrition is
huge and also the serious amount of data
we're now having from the microbiome and
it is very complex to figure out how to
keep humans healthy for as long as
possible
yet that is one of the most important
things because as we get older it's like
we have a library and that we want to
keep adding books to the library and see
the new connections that are made the
new creative potential that can arise
later in our lives versus like what
happens in neurodegeneration is just
like the library gets burned down and
well you're bringing up a key point and
it relates to this whole deep Medicine
umbrella concept the point is where
we're gonna go is that all your data as
long as you want to be getting a virtual
medical coach all your data will be
continually inputted and assimilated and
fed back to you in terms of guidance
mm-hmm and as soon as we get the text
part straight it'll also be the entire
medical literature pertaining to you
about a condition that you're at risk
for or that you actually have when
you're trying to manage better already
we're seeing this for diabetes now
starting to emerge but eventually it's
going to be in the next five years for
your general health and so you'll have
this avatar that will communicate with
you on your phone or your smart speaker
or whatever and I'll say how you know
you haven't slept right the last several
days and everything indicates you know
you're a much higher stress level yeah
and that's why we're seeing your blood
pressure starting to get out of whack
and this is like notice like 11 o'clock
spray some lavender place and productive
music and well maybe may play your
favorite song but it also might say you
know what
you just haven't been getting any
exercise and you're not you really got
to get back on track and be like your
your conscience how trying to help you
to stay healthy now why is that
important because first of all it's not
for everybody but just like your kind of
voice assistant or your you know your
daily life assistant to tell you to go
to the airport or the traffic's bad or
whatever it's gonna be for your health
the difference here is that this is
about preventing a condition a dream
that we've never fulfilled before now
we've had general prevention like don't
smoke cigarettes or you know wear
seatbelts or things like that but we
haven't had individualized prediction
now we have these things called
polygenic risk scores and I can say this
person has a much higher risk of heart
disease
or much higher risk of colon cancer or
whatever several conditions that are
common we've got that now before you
ever get that's the whole key is that
your coach so you don't ever get a
wheeze if you're a risk for asthma or
you don't ever get a polyp if you're at
risk for colon cancer and on and on so
that is exciting
but you know it's just the beginning
stages we're at the nascent the fact
that we can even id8 about it is
exciting yes but that's where we're
headed so then let's let's see if we can
then visualize this so then we have this
constant stream of data that's coming
from our bodies and our health that is
likely from different things like the
cameras it on our devices that are able
to like read our biometrics that way or
other things like all the other just
sensor sweets in general wearables all
different types of things then we have
that that is constantly being fed into
really strong cloud compute potential
that has the entire medical corpus
ideally this is the future hopefully
entire medical corpus that's constantly
seeing okay Eric's current States
compared to the core basis of literature
and dynamically making recommen
as a virtual medical coach for Erick's
optimal health trajectory so on this
light tree of possibilities that exists
we could get Eric to live until 96 years
of age but Eric needs to do these
specific steps in order to get to that
spot
otherwise if there's a bifurcating
moment of not listening and getting that
two hours of sleep instead of that eight
like we asked that they may slowly be
shedding days and weeks off of that
optimal but yeah I don't know that it's
gonna be lifespan changing but it may be
quality of life genius because if you
don't have one of these conditions that
you are at risk for that's just one less
thing you have to deal with throughout
your life you know whether you have to
have stents for your arteries or whether
you have to you know keep going more
frequently for procedures you know we
don't have evidence that we have
transforming lifespan in store but I
think I mean if you don't have have an
asthma attack ever in your life because
it's preventable would not be better
than having to take daily inhalers and
Medicus medicines and worrying about you
know could that sort of thing so we're
talking really about quality of life
perhaps yeah if we ever get to beyond
health span if we ever get to lifespan
that would be a welcome thing but you
know I'm not trying to be too bold in
our expectations I rather be setting
things even what we're talking about
here is quite ambitious David a feeling
in peak health yeah that you preserve
your health rather than having the years
that you're around that you're suffering
even more chronic conditions because
they're of your long wrap your around
long enough you're gonna have some
problems in some conditions if we can
minimize that and keep you well
preserved then you're probably gonna be
enjoying your life a lot more yeah and
then Eric why don't we ask you about
those perverse incentives that currently
exist so the lack of inclusive stake
holding with visit
and patience is a major one the amount
of lobbyist money that's being poured
into the pharmaceutical industry it's
tough because it takes so much money to
make something that we hope of men's
health and then if it's and then so hard
to test it because it's so hard to
control that single variable in such a
complex piece of art like the body what
do we do for increasing inclusive steak
holding between physicians and patients
increasing empathy and and while
simultaneously having a strong
electronic health record is this
something like we take the voice and
then we parse that for text and then the
text Auto and puts it into the
electronic health record so they don't
have to do it and then also on the like
fake food sides as well as how do we
have more inclusive steak holding and
less self dealing yeah well firstly what
we do need to do is get back the human
bond that is the essence of Medicine so
the relationship between patients and
doctors patients and all clinicians
whether it be nurses physical therapists
pharmacist um you name it right now
that's fractured its eroded seriously
you wrote it and it's been a steady
demise over decades and that's largely
because of the big business of
healthcare and pharma pharmaceuticals is
just one relatively small part of that
story so how do we get it back and I
think we can in the era of AI as it
kicks in you already mentioned one of
many strategies which is keyboard
liberation keyboard liberation yeah
that's basically using voice the
conversation which is the the most
salient aspect of that yeah that
interaction and synthesizing the note
from it turns out the notes you get from
the voice conversation are far better
than the notes that are currently in
these electronic records interesting
because those records are 80% cut and
pasted from the prior name and that note
is erroneous and so what we do is just
have a
perpetual transmission of erroneous
notes whereas a conversation which
captures the real-time interaction is
essential because it that firstly that
is all archived so patients oftentimes
you know they don't really can't absorb
everything when they're talking to a
doctor because it's a lots happening
it's about their body and they're all
worried and you know it often times they
may have their spouse with them or a
family member and they still it's hard
to get it all absorb so they can have an
archive of that conversation yeah to
listen to if they want there's no reason
why they shouldn't but also more
importantly the synthesis of that note
the critical elements are then as you
say speech to text and very quickly
we've learned that within a small number
of patients for a given doctor their
voice it captures it really well and the
notes are just excellent and their goods
going to keep getting better of course
because they're said autodidactic story
just get more accurate and here we want
the patients to edit the notes too
because that'll just even add more
authenticity and accuracy any rate so
that part is starting to take off and
there's different parts of the world and
that's just one there's so many other
ways at AI that's natural language
processing and machine learning but
you've got AI to tee up a person's
record to go through the hundreds of
pages of labs and path reports if there
are any scans and all the other things
that happened to that person or in their
family history their social history you
have that a machine to do that for you
to do that accurately and tee it up so
you don't have to spend hours trying to
sort through and miss a lot of stuff
because you get distracted or because
it's just so much stuff then you have of
course the ability to have the images
interpreted as we talked about through
initially through a scan to not miss
things or the slide or a skin lesion or
you know all sorts of things that
machines are really good at they don't
miss things that humans and experts
can so you have offloading to machines
you've got also the ability for patients
taking more charge with their data like
you mentioned they may have sensors on
them have their electronic record and
they may have their genome and their gut
microbiome and all of a sudden they're
getting feedback and they're getting
more autonomy there's a lot of things
that are in medicine today they don't we
are we could do without a doctor
diagnosis a urinary tract infection an
ear infection a skin rash and the long
long list of common things that are not
serious they're not life-threatening but
they could be just validated through
algorithms so patients can do themselves
again decompressing the load on
clinicians so we're going to see all
these things take hold and one of the
biggest longer-term is that where you
will gut out hospitals because the
hospital is the biggest hit to the
health economy the staffing and the
facilities and that's a third of the
three point five three point six
trillion dollars in the US a year so if
we obviously we're not going to get rid
of intensive care units or operating
rooms or mergency rooms or fancy imaging
equipment but the regular hospital room
would be better served in a patient's
bedroom yeah or even anywhere in their
home or on the go the reason being is we
can exquisitely Manar people today and
as as soon as we get to the point of
having that multimodal data getting
properly processed then we can say you
know what it's safer to have the patient
at home at a tiny fraction of the cost
wouldn't that be great so that's where
some of the biggest changes we're going
to see they're pervasive there isn't one
specialty in medicine or primary care
that isn't affected we're talking about
everything from paramedics to palliative
care
there isn't one walk of life or in the
in the whole life story from in vitro
fertilization all the way to end-of-life
care that wouldn't be affected so it's a
very
impact like I've never seen so move ha
and it's so important for us to to
democratize the benefits widely quickly
and also important for us to pursue this
in a way that is ethically and morally
righteous and and also that that if move
will get to some more of these things
but also that is geopolitically
collaborative so let's um let's touch on
this you mentioned this is there some
big part of what you just said
we are architecting new data flows right
now for the data to be structured in a
way that can easily be readable and that
can easily then have all different types
of artificial intelligence Apple
methodologies applied to it in order for
us to understand what's actually going
on within ourselves so does a there's a
future with Ark with these new
architectures of data flows potentially
look like ownership of our own data and
then being able to do things like almost
in a sense have a valve and be able to
like open the valve and let my biometric
data flow into like scripts for example
and have scripts be able to leverage my
biometric data for research purposes
right well this is a really big topic
about control and ownership of data
because the way it works today is that
people don't own their data they have to
beg and grovel to get pieces of their
data because it's distributed in many
different places first of all there's
not even a home for person sensor data
or their genome or if in the future more
and more their microbiome of their gut
and sort of environmental sensors
there's lots of things that we don't
even collect and put in the medical
record of today but then each person
often has many different interactions
with doctors of
different places and different even in
the same city or town
and that data just sits at different
places and it's never collated so one of
the problems we have in the era of
artificial intelligence is nobody has
all their data unless they happened to
be born in a health system and never
left it and all that's you know
aggregated perfectly well that's pretty
unusual plus even that person doesn't
have all their sensor data in their
genome and whatnot so we have we're in
flux right now where there's many modes
of data and it's fragmented and it's
hard to get at at all some of it if
we're older is a lot of its on page in
paper not even digitized
so we have a problem because inputs is
basically what is the story here for AI
and you have limited inputs then your
output is not going to be is it's gonna
be compromised it's not going to be as
good as it can be so we are firstly not
fessing up that we have a problem and we
have to override this somehow or other
and then secondly we have a security and
privacy issue that's deep in this
country we don't have these gdpr
standards at Europe adopted we're much
more tolerant of hacking in cyber
thievery and holding hostage health
systems for their data all these sort of
things that are just atrocious and we're
doing very little to stop it and also
juxtaposed with what looks like to be a
very collective approach of like the
People's Republic of China yeah well
like you know an Estonian people own all
their data it sits on a blockchain type
format and you make the call like you
said I won't open the valve to give my
sensor data to this research program or
to give this medical data to a doctor
that I'm going to see or I trust you
make the call and the reason why that's
attractive and that model really was
initiated there is that when you have
control of the data and it sits at the
level of an individual or a family
then you don't have the cyber-hacking
potential if you talk to the gurus of
cybersecurity I say keep it in the
smallest units as possible the more it
sits on big servers the more its a
target because it turns out that the
data of our health is far more valuable
than our financial data
it turns out that it's at least five X
in the dark web or more value because
it's used for false medical claims in
this country is used to get
prescriptions like opiates it's used for
identity theft medical identity theft so
well our medical data is really valuable
we're not protecting it enough we don't
aggregate it you know it very well
and that's needs a shake-up that needs
priority and it hasn't gotten it yet so
you know we can learn from other places
and it's surprising how little attention
has been paid to this ok let's um let's
touch on how you gave these examples of
like ok Estonia is doing things a
specific way China is doing things
another way the United States Europe etc
doing things in different ways now we
also mentioned like the importance of
democratizing these advancements in
health care and making them accessible
to people being ethical as we do that
something that I thought that was really
interesting was that your you had a
recent post with ty Fuli about Jun
Wang's I carbon X and Jaime Heywood's
patients like him right and there was a
order from the United States for I
carbon X to withdraw its funding and
ownership of patients like me well they
had to yes there through the Trump
administration there was a order of
divestiture yeah whereby patients like
me could not be owned by I Carbon X a
Chinese company and they ultimately were
after that piece was published they
they're in there ready to close
terms
to be acquired by United health in the
u.s. because of this force divestiture
whoa so this was a real bad omen because
I carbon acts beautifully was a great
partnership with patients like me they
hadn't done anything wrong in terms of
breach of data of any patients of the
700 thousand people in patients like me
and the idea was that they were going to
be like this voice medical coach they
were going to they were working on that
that that was to give them you know a
large cohort of people with diverse
conditions diverse demographics with all
the things that they're doing so it was
actually I think a bad sign of the times
which is in part why Typhoo and I wrote
that piece because we want to see
collaboration this is an opportunity
what we're I don't know if we'll ever
have it again
mm-hm and what and not only that but the
Chinese the u.s. relationship is kind of
at a nadir right now a lot of tension
the trade war and all sorts of
accusations of scientists as spies and I
mean it's it's really the worst I've
ever seen in my career
meanwhile we're all like friends you
know I thought yeah like we have friends
in Beijing or Shanghai or whatever and
they have friends in New York and LA and
stuff yeah so that's going on in in the
foreground them but in the background we
got some serious of concerns now health
is interestingly of mutual interest and
there's so much complementarity of what
China has and what the US has and if we
could work together well what about all
the other countries around the world
that could join in but if we're if we're
using the planet and habitant health as
a goal and yes it's a big goal and that
could help improve relationships even
outside of Health between the countries
so I haven't given up hope for this but
I hope at the same time that we
recognize at this point you're bringing
up is I forced divestiture
is going to really lead to more polarity
it's going to escalate the tension
rather than the opposite so you know
it's really unfortunate that this has
occurred I'm hoping it's just a
transient thing that we get back on
track we we outlined in the nature
biotech article how we could go forward
and with an open science open platform
resource way and have joint governance
and once we get started and develop this
infrastructure of data yes where it's
federated learnings this is a type of AI
which is really another exciting sub
type where you never take the data
outside of that country or Health System
Hospital doctor's office it's all
machine train it's like at the edge
instead of in the cloud
it's all done and so you never have to
worry about breaches of privacy and if
we did that so that no country would
have to worry about their data leaving
or being stolen or hacked the using this
federated type of AI we could we
couldn't even actually advance the
concept but now that is a an alluring
potential it's something that deserves
to be tried at least in a pilot way yes
the importance of the United States and
China to be able to cooperate and
maximize flourishing for the rest of the
planet together especially with things
like the belt and road initiative coming
up on the eastern hemisphere and just
the United States and China being the
top two economies on the planet just
that our way of actually being able to
really more deeply spiritually work
together is critical it's one of the top
most important things in the world and
also within our ethos and so that's why
the you know we're coming up on
partnership interviews and delivering a
talk at Peking University in Beijing in
September and I'm really looking forward
to that and it's just going to be one of
the most critical things that happens in
the next couple of decades is being able
to figure that relationship out more
effect
all right let's um let's make sure we
talk about the heart I think this is
really important to talk about the heart
in our just the entire evolution of our
planet in our bodies on this planet and
then the organ systems within those
bodies and then the heart specifically
being such a beautiful organ that gives
us a hundred thousand beats a day of
being able to help us live and help us
survive and so I'm just very spiritually
tied to the heart like I really loved it
on just like a huge spiritual level and
and I'm just curious what are your
thoughts on on the heart and on a
spiritual level about the importance of
the heart well you know I that's might
been my career you know I got bored as a
cardiologist and 85 so it's now 34 35
almost years I think it's a phenomenal
organ the fact that this pump is is
there for you you know every second and
giving you the nourishment of every cell
in your body essentially so yeah
spiritually I mean that's why there's so
much overlap with love and the heart and
you know I think there's no question
about that connect and you know I think
that there are obviously every organ is
important in the body this is a central
part of life so I can understand your
spiritual connection to it I've been
very lucky to be able to work in this
area of trying to preserve people's
heart health and it turns out you know
it's oftentimes a mixed bag of genetics
so people do everything they can to take
care of themselves and still wind up
with heart trouble and it oftentimes is
bad lifestyle as well it's just kind of
admixture of everything of nature and
but you know overall we've made
tremendous strides in heart health over
the course of my career in fact that's
why I got into it in the first place I
wasn't even planning on being a
cardiologist but I so excited by what
was happening when I was training in the
early 80s that it was clear that that
was going to be a hot area to be in and
and that was going to be an area that
would be stimulating and and turns out
it's been one that probably in many ways
have outpaced other areas of Medicine in
terms of progress doesn't mean that we
we still have lots of heart disease but
you know people dying of heart attacks
today is much less than used to be the
case people having less heart damage
many things are far better than they
were in fact just to give you a quick
story on that Allen when I was training
if you had a heart attack
what we did was we you know gave you
morphine for the pain and oxygen and
basically you know kind of prayed that
you would get through it because we
didn't have anything to stop the heart
attack in its tracks and so now
obviously we we do everything Canada we
store the blood supply and most people
do have heard stored blood supply and
people dying of heart attack is you know
markedly it's plummeted so that used to
be the most common cause of death heart
impact and heart disease and now it's
still important but over time you know
cancer is overtaking it and you know I
think it's exciting to see the progress
because you know we think about 30 years
is a little almost like a little drop in
the bucket of time when you think about
the universe and to see that kind of
progress in a short time is is
relatively astounding yes Eric would you
say that we all come from the same
source you know I'm not a real kind of
religious person so I don't know I if
you talk about source of evolution yeah
I could get
to that but you know I really don't yes
but as far as you know the guy create
man and all that I don't know I but all
coming from the same source of evolution
yeah oh I I am a strong believer in that
yeah that principle that we evolved from
you know organisms of lesser complexity
and we're continuing to evolve Albia
perhaps you know at a different pace but
ya know I that I would agree and and
let's go backwards far enough that so
then if we go from yet from humans to
sing solo we're gonna stir this to the
initial root of evolution on this planet
and the star systems and then what we
hypothesize is this Big Bang what about
prior to that does this feel like it's
just one big creation that's occurred
and it's like a big beautiful painting
with different strokes and the big
symphony of different notes you know I
don't know something I think about and
it's hard to know it's just you know
we're here for a little bit of time and
we can be you know quite introspective
about it but these are some of the
unknowns I wish I had an answer for you
and then what do you think about how
lots of indigenous wisdom around the
world is saying that our disconnection
from nature our disconnection from this
origin story of ours is the reason why
we have so many of the issues yeah well
you know that's like the religious wars
and you know the whole idea of this
disbelief anti science you know the
devolution of man and our hold of our
biology is somehow it didn't occur I
mean I have a hard time with that
because I think that particularly
the climate right now of anti-science
with the idea that you know evolution
shouldn't be taught in schools and that
sort of thing that really gets me pretty
riled up so you know I think that this
is an area where just like the diet
there's a lot of tribalism you know
about people that are really big on
let's say ketogenic diet and people are
really big on this or that I mean
interesting we have a lot of divisive
miss and we don't really have tolerance
or belief in where there's hard
scientific proof I don't think there's
any question about the if you trace
evolutionary biology you know were where
we came from but you know there's people
that negate that enforcement it's a it's
a very difficult area you have the
importance of nuance the importance of
multivariate e of humility of compassion
of having really good thought-provoking
conversations but having good dialectic
all right
and how about then what would you say is
the
teleology of this whole human experiment
well he's a pretty deep question which I
did none of these recent ones had I
anticipated you know I just kind of like
the meaning of life and you know it's
it's a it's it's tough to all I know is
that you know I try to have input in the
time the short time all around to try to
make a difference to try to help people
at you try to connect deeply with my
family who I'm lucky enough to have all
close together here in San Diego and you
know it's sometimes beyond that it's
hard you know I contemplated I'm sure a
lot of people do you know it that whole
having seen so many people who were
alive one second and dead the next it
gives you a different sense about life
and how short it can be and how sudden
it can be not there and that's one thing
I medicine it's somewhat unique that you
have an essence of life yes and you know
it to me that and the fact that you know
I've had so much of a burden of disease
and a lot on my family my parents and
relatives it even gave me more
motivation to try to make the best of
each day but I still know that however
many years that I get to be on this side
of the dirt that you know what it's a
small tiny tiny thing in the big picture
and even whatever you can have eyes oh
but you added to our to our species if
you will to one planet in our community
whatever you want to call it that you
can only go so far you know you kind of
the ability to make substantive changes
is a tall order it's probably impossible
you chip away at a little bit mm-hmm do
you feel like you came to the planet
with a North Star with with with an
ideal goal and mission that you wanted
to achieve here and that you're
fulfilling that no I'd probably too
lofty in fact I know it's too long no I
think it's really more that you know I
when I was a kid I watched a lot of my
relatives die I remember you know being
a kid and going up various funerals and
then I saw my parents died at a young
age and you know I had a higher
appreciation for if you're lucky enough
to be here just to be here no less to do
something and then I was just lucky
enough to
the ability to go to get the great
education and pursue a path that I could
feel like this I'm aligned I'm excited
I'm passionate about what I do and I'm
lucky enough to feel a kind of spurts of
creativity and being able to inspire
other people so I'm lucky enough to have
a great team here that I get to work
with and and we try to do the same
reverberate our work and ideas more
broadly so I I feel exceptionally lucky
but a lot of that happens by accident
you know you know some of it is setting
goals but a lot of it is you know just
lucky to wind up with people who are
simpatico who are you know kind of the
same what drives in what makes them tick
there's a lot of commonality and that
makes it happen it doesn't ever feel
like those synchronicities that are
lining up in your trajectory of
achieving your goals are potentially
there for a reason maybe as lessons or
as as experiences to help you level up
well you know I it's it's it isn't clear
you know oftentimes what I'll do is I'll
say you know we got to do this this is a
big thing and sometimes it'll work and
we'll get there other times you know we
I remember you know when I was back in
Cleveland and I started a new medical
school there hadn't been one in 26 years
and it was really difficult because
where I worked at Cleveland Clinic
there was no degree granting Authority
so we couldn't start a medical school
you know like that and we had to work
with the Case Western in town which is
the University and they already had a
health system and the last thing I
wanted was another medical school in
town and basically like taken down the
Berlin Wall and we what to do it and we
started this medical school was the
first one in 26 years in the United
now that took a couple years of
dedicated effort I'm really proud of
that we were able to do it so that's the
kind of thing where if you just keep
that you know working on it and you get
can you have to convince a lot of people
take down on what was walls of hostility
you almost like be a shuttle ambassador
it's that something that is worth it
it's worth it because it'll train
generations of doctors in the future now
there's been certainly many things you
know go after and don't be a failure
no never materialised - so you know you
have to offset if you don't try then
what I've learned though and this
happened more over the course of a
careers don't do little things I mean it
isn't worth the energy you know put your
put your resources your time into things
that are transformative potentially and
transcend yeah yeah because otherwise if
you're just trying to do incremental
stuff it's usually you're gonna wind up
put a lot of time into that and it
really isn't gonna be worth it and you
better better off to fail when it's
something you know major because at
least you gave it a shot and and you
know what a lot of times they're going
to succeed particularly if you get to
work with people it's very hard to do
this alone and you and you really got to
get you know a kind of team
collaborative approach but if you do
that and you set big goals that some
people might say are beyond reach
unattainable impossible even those are
probably the best goals yeah as long as
you're sound as long as there is you
know unmet need and and a real purpose
those are the ones that I like to do
like why so beautifully said and then
how about if you were to have
ability to make augmentations right now
to bait to children that are being born
into the world let's say it's even like
your children that are being born into
the world and you have the ability to
make augmentations to the child being
born what area of their development
would you choose to augment first yeah I
don't think that I'd want to go there to
augmentation I still won't be into
nature but you know I I had with genetic
engineering and trying to figure out
exactly which which ways that we can
augment metabolism more intelligent yeah
I know I I'm not I think there's a big
ethical quandary with that yeah because
there's no real you know it's a grey
zone you know what are you gonna do make
more athletic more intelligent and more
what you know water what we've kind of
been doing that though over the years of
evolution we ourselves have been
genetically pairing for fitness in terms
of intelligence or athletics or strength
or metabolism or all different well but
now it's different because now we have
these powerful tools like genome editing
and we watched the reckless use of that
in China where they're basically the
fellow he Janicki was getting couples
with the father with HIV and saying that
we could make sure that the baby
well CRISPR the baby's at the embryo
less state so that baby doesn't have to
worry about getting HIV well guess what
that wasn't going to happen anyway you
didn't need CRISPR and so it basically
did and and the genome editing part was
so reckless because there's all sorts of
things that can happen outside of the
zone of editing no less in the zone that
you're trying to edit of a genome so
that was a disaster and that was the
first foray of an embryo but this is a
powerful tool which has potentially lots
of side effects and it shouldn't be
augmenting at the embryo level in my
view it what it should be doing is
trying to treat diseases
Dizzy's yeah let's say that once put
that that should say that wasn't that
augmenting well let's say eradication of
disease is already awesome we're all
already on board for that okay now we
have the augmentation side of things
yeah well you know I looked at
augmentation is having a baby
you know infertile couple that's all
mini its augmenting their family I hit
my granddaughter with an IVF baby and I
still look at that as a miracle yeah and
she's really healthy she's just like 15
months old and it was secondary
infertility because my daughter had
already had a healthy boy but I still
think that's extraordinary but to
manipulate that embryo further besides
just being able to get an embryo that's
viable and to term pregnancy you know
it's really dicey I mean we IVF now is
is it still got lots of failures and the
it's a tremendous expense it's often you
know couples go through multiple rounds
is all sorts of hormonal injections
until you see somebody I'm gonna go
through this you have no idea how
complicated and tough it is and this is
something that here we're talking about
augmenting we can't even get you know
just a simple let's just have a natural
baby you know that is different than
we're gonna start doing genome editing
of that embryo so I I'm not into that
you know interesting I think that I
wonder if your children 50 years from
now yeah and their children 50 years
from now will say that I can't believe
that you weren't genome editing back
then because because in 50 years it
seems to be the trajectory is moving to
that to be a norm very similarly to how
we're slaughtering billions of animals
for food versus growing clean meat
children again will be like a complete
you were doing that back well you know
you could be right
that there will be more there will be
some use at the embryo level that you
know get out these genes that would
cause risk of cancer yeah or Alzheimer's
or you know whatever disease that's
possible I if it's preventing
significant diseases I could see that
but on many I see it as artificial
augmentation whereby you know instead of
having cosmetic surgery to look pretty
now we're caught you now we're actually
going in to you in life and remember any
transmit anything that we're doing there
is transmittable so we're changing the
species alright and so this is you now
we're now we're playing with not fire
we're playing we odd we're playing
biology with the human genome and the
future of the species so if you if
you're gonna be doing that and you're
gonna be transmitting that it better be
for something damn good and you know I
think diseases
okay if they're serious disease and you
know and you have side effects and
absolutely wants to get somebody more
intelligent you know what we're trying
to solve these grand physics challenges
on you know I see III have a little
different solution than you on this I
actually think the human mind is is the
talent that we have in general is
extraordinary I I mean I meet people who
are brilliant all the time and you know
far smarter than I'll ever be and ever
was and you know I think and we see
young people coming up I we have so that
high school interns spend the summer yet
and it make me feel like a complete
[ __ ] you know they're just incredible
so I don't worry about the intellect at
all and I don't worry about athletics
because we already have here a worship
of sports I don't see any good rationale
for the augmentation side you're
bringing up I I'm keen on the disease
burden thing if we can do that but
that's a big if big if and you know
right now we're talking about rare
diseases not your common disease so
see ya okay maybe an another layer of
conversation we can unpack some of the
other potential conversational points
around this
let's let some visit the last couple
questions which is Eric do you think
that were in a simulation a simulation I
don't know about that I think we're in a
real reality zone and I mean you don't
want to treat it like the simulation you
get one chance you know you if you if
you think of it as a simulation then
that's probably that's probably not
ideal
it doesn't have to be mutually exclusive
if you see it as a simulation you can
see it as a game and it's so important
for you to achieve your mission and your
goals here so can actually in ways also
maybe even excite you more to achieve
your divine purpose by viewing it in
that way so doesn't necessarily have to
be exclusive from being serious about
life oh yeah I'll take your point that's
a you know that's your perspective it's
okay hmm
okay and then what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world I
think love of another human being is
probably what I put it up there you know
I think any of course not just one but
there's a real dearth of that and it's
why we have so much you know divisive
nough sand Wars and but you know a human
level that bond for each other to me is
its beauty it's more beautiful than the
most beautiful beach or place on earth
nature we don't have enough of it and
when you're in touch with it you say
well how could it be better than that so
that's what I see is the pinnacle of
beauty we can carry that love with us on
a moment-to-moment basis through our
breath through our gratitude
through our connection to the planet to
the ecosystem that sustains us
connection to each other yeah no you're
right I mean if we had love and we if it
got expressed and how we take care of
our planet we'd be a whole lot better
off than we are right now so yeah I mean
if we could get that you know to be
expressed in many other ways it'd be
great we don't have enough of it just to
each other you know less to get it to be
reflected in our walk of life so yeah I
agree with you Eric this has been such a
wonderful conversation really
enlightening thank you well thank you
you made me think thank you so much for
coming on the show thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking also check out
the links in the bio below to Eric's
profile page on scripts as wikipedia has
Twitter and check out his a new book
deep medicine how a I can make health
care human again that link is in the bio
check that out and have more
conversations that your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media about deep medicine about
these subjects that we were talking
about today talk more about it and try
and figure out how we're gonna maximize
our prosperity through that age I'll
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the organizations the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe in
support them help them grow support
simulation our links are below help us
grow as well our paypal patreon
cryptocurrency links are down there you
can design cool merch and get paid all
different kinds of things and also go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace
that's a rat there right that was so fun
they don't see good questions they awful